Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to talk about image colorization.
This is a problem where we take and old old
black and white photo, run it through one
of these amazing new learning-based algorithms,
and out comes an image that is properly colored.
The obvious application of this is, of course,
image restoration.
What you see here is some amazing results
with this new method, so clearly, this can
now be done very well, and you will find out
in a moment how challenging this problem is.
But there are also, less obvious applications,
for instance, image compression too.
Just imagine that we wouldn’t have to transmit
colored images over the internet, black and
white photos would be fine, and if there is
an AI-based algorithm in every computer, they
would be able to restore the colors perfectly.
This would save a lot of bandwidth and energy
and would be a glorious thing to do.
So, how well do the current learning-based
algorithms do at image colorization?
Wow, that is a hard, hard question, and, let’s
find out together why.
First, let’s look at the results of this
new method that you saw so far against previously
existing techniques.
Here is the black and white input image, and
here is the ground truth output that we have
concealed from the algorithms.
Only we see the result, this will remain our
secret, and the algorithms only have access
to the black and white input.
Let’s start.
Yup, these are all learning based methods,
so they all appear to know what a strawberry
is, and they color it accordingly.
So far so good.
However, this problem is much, much harder
than just colorizing strawberries.
We have grapes too!
That does not sound like much, but there are
many problems with grapes.
For instance, there are many kinds of grapes,
and they are also translucent, and therefore
their appearance depends way more on the lighting
in the scene.
That’s a problem, because the algorithm
not only has to know what objects are present
in this image, but what the lighting around
them looks like, and how their material properties
should interact with this kind of lighting.
Goodness, that is a tremendously difficult
problem.
Previous methods did a reasonably good job
at colorizing the image, but the grapes remain
a challenge.
And now, hold on to your papers and let’s
see the new method!
Wow, just look at that!
The translucency of the grapes is captured
beautifully, and the colors are very close
to the ground truth.
But that was just one example.
What if we generate a lot of results and show
it to a few people.
What do the users say?
Let’s compare the DeOldify technique with
this new method.
DeOldify is an interesting specimen as it
combines three previously published techniques
really well, but it is not a published paper.
Fortunately, its source code is available,
and it is easy to compare results against
it.
So let’s see how it fares against this new
technique!
Apparently, they trade blows, but more often
than not, the new method seems to come out
ahead.
Now note that we have a secret.
And that secret is that we can see the reference
images, which are hidden from the algorithms.
This helps us a great deal, because we can
mathematically compare the results of the
learning algorithms to the reference.
So what do the numbers say?
Yup, now you see why I said that it is very
hard to tell which algorithm is the best,
because they all trade blows, and depending
on how we measure the difference between two
images, we get a different winner.
All this is true… until we have a look at
the results with the new paper.
If you have been holding on to your papers,
now squeeze that paper, because this new method
smokes the competition on every dataset, regardless
of what we are measuring.
So what is this black magic?
What is behind this wizardry?
This method uses an off-the-shelf object detection
module that takes the interesting elements
out of the image, which are then colorized
one by one.
Of course, this way, we haven’t colorized
the entire image, so parts of it would remain
black and white, which is clearly not what
we are looking for.
As a remedy, let’s color the entire image
independently from the previous process.
Now we have an okay-quality result where the
colors have reached the entirety of the image,
but now, what do we do?
We also colorized the objects independently,
so some things are colorized twice, and they
are different.
This doesn’t make any sense whatsoever…until
we introduce a novel fusion module to the
process, that stitches these overlapping results
into one coherent output.
And the results are absolutely amazing.
So how much do we have to wait to get all
this?
If we take a small-ish image, the colorization
can take place five times a second, and just
two more papers down the line, this will easily
run in real time I am sure.
You know what, with the pace of progress in
machine learning research today, maybe even
just one paper down the line.
So, what about the limitations?
You remember that this contains an object
detector, and if it goes haywire, all bets
are off and we might have to revert to the
only okay full-image colorization method.
Also, note that all of these comparisons showcased
image colorization, while DeOldify is also
capable of colorizing videos as well.
But of course, one step at a time.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!